With an army of supermen millions strong
because that is vaught's true destiny
and you will be the man who will lead us
you are everything that we dreamed of
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for the boys season
two episode
6 stormfront and frenchie would like to
dedicate this episode to the golden
girls thank you for being a friend
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite
crazy moment from the episode on the
video obviously careful for spoilers
from episode 6 if you haven't seen it
yet we'll do top 10 and comic book
easter eggs as we go along
there were a lot of comic book easter
eggs just starting with number 10 the
title of the episode
the title is the bloody doors off as in
blow the freaking doors off
it's actually a comic book reference to
the title of the very final volume of
the boys comic vol
12. that's the end of the story there
are some easter eggs for things that
happen
during that that they do set up and
tease during the episode but
mostly the plot of the final volume of
the comic book is very different from
what they actually did in the episode
it's also a reference to the doors of
the mental hospital being blown off
their hinges
literally by the new supers that vog
created we get a great flashback
opening the episode with frenchie and
his former girlfriend just evangelizing
the golden girls
setting up the theme that they tag at
the end of the episode too
he is a hardcore golden girls fan he and
deadpool would get along
he just explains that when he first came
to the united states he spent a lot of
time watching their show in his free
time and the lesson that he learned from
them was that just like their group he
made his own family
that's also a metaphor for the boys team
they become
like a family there is a cool contrast
in the episode between that really
wholesome idea that frenchie has
in the creepy cult vibes that both the
deep and storm front give off when
they're trying to espouse the same type
of sentiment
so number nine starlight and huey in
their relationship versus homelander
and stormfront in their relationship or
their super toxic relationship
frenchie's removing starlight's tracking
device from her neck they joke about
huey
being in love with her but they try to
keep their relationship on the dl they
are the most wholesome couple on the
show
which is a really nice contrast to the
next scene of homelander in stormfront
going on a really
really dark superhero date in the
alleyway while they do it on top of the
corpse of the criminal that they torture
then kill
as if that's foreplay while they're
slowly getting ready to do it
whoever edited this episode and chose
the song list deserves an award the
soundtrack was amazing
number eight starlight joins the boys
formally so kimiko
bonds with starlight immediately just
because she remembers how much she
helped her in the previous episodes
but butcher in starlight's bonding just
takes the entire episode takes a little
bit longer for him to come around on her
one of the big themes of the episode
between the different character groups
is finding common ground like between
frenchie and lamplighter then butcher
and starlight
between homelander and stormfront each
person hated the other
on some deep fundamental level because
of some perceived or
actual past tragedy but by the end of
the episode
each of their relationships does a full
180.
butcher starts out the episode wanting
to use starlight as bait for vaught
chum for shark-infested waters as he
says the deep also tries to come back to
quote-unquote his
old family to the seven what i need an
excuse to visit my friends
he is the worst worst james bond ever
as a lot of you suspected maeve's plan
for him was to have him go to the bottom
of the ocean and use his powers to get
fish to look for the black box
which he did not find but instead did
find a gopro with the footage that she
needed
the number seven probably one of the
funniest story lines from the episode
the deep
tries to bring a train into his cult
would you like a fresca
suddenly everyone's turning around and
running in the opposite way anytime you
see a fresca you know that [ __ ] is about
to go down
they even follow up with a really creepy
moment with stormfront from their last
encounter
obviously she's super racist i feel like
that's super obvious
they brought back gorham business
character as the leader of that creepy
church he had a much bigger scene in
this episode and i know a lot of you
wondered about the timeless cameos there
were a bunch of actors from the timeless
tv series that showed up in previous
episodes
the reason that happened is because the
showrunner of the boys was also the
showrunner of the timeless tv show so
he's just bringing back actors that he
used to work with on other tv shows
i hope there's some big payoff with that
fresca joke by the end of the season
like they say that there's some sort of
additive that the church puts in it like
the church
owns the fresca brand but actually i
think coca-cola owns fresca
either way it's hilarious the church
knows everything about a train and
they're going to hold it over him and they
kind of blackmail him
into either joining or at least helping
them with their purpose
because they want to get people inside
the seven inside vaude that's their
whole thing they just want more power
too
just like vaught wants more power and
wants to get people in the white house
number six all the frenchie flashbacks
and the origin of the boys so we get a
ton of flashbacks in this episode
obviously most of them are focused on
frenchie's character he's probably one
of the biggest characters this week
but we see frenchie meeting mallory for
the very first time after he gets
caught at that bank robbery that they
talked about and she's completely
impressed with his
quote-unquote chemist abilities to
create all kinds of weapons to
neutralize superheroes
because obviously she's the leader of
the boys and they're taking down
superheroes left and right so they need
someone with his ingenuity
they make a bunch of references to
marvel and dc characters
so when they talk about frenchie taking
down behemoth with the giant xanax bomb
to neutralize his rage powers
obviously that's a marvel reference to
avengers in the hulk
the matter he gets the stronger he gets
cue all the memes
sun's getting real low buddy they
mention cold snap who's probably their
version of captain cold
malchemical that she name drops probably
sounds like their version of chemo from
the dc universe
but number five the boys versus sage
grove
so there is so much stuff going on at
sage grove here you have a couple
different story lines that sort of
collide while they're trying to break
into that mental hospital
you have all the stuff that's going on
between butcher and starlight but then
you have the actual sage grove story
they find out that the whole reason why
vat is experimenting on these people
isn't to create more terrorists
is actually to try and normalize
compound v so that they can actually
give it to adults
safely so this is actually a big comic
book easter egg the way it works in the
comics is that it's actually so
unstable that when you give it to adults
they either explode like lamplighter
says
or they actually get powers but most of
the time like nine times out of ten
they explode and compound v costs
billions of dollars to manufacture
so that's why there are so few
superheroes because you have to give it
to children
it's expensive to manufacture and most
of the people that take it wind up dying
while they're busy running around
learning about sage grove inside
butcher and starlight have it out and
she basically tells them you're no
better than homelander you're just as
big of a crap bag as he is
and she's not wrong they were trying to
be very clear when they set that up the
first couple of episodes with him
crossing the line
in the whole theme with him and hughie
obviously he comes back from the brink
so i think
the message you're left with at the end
of the episode is that butcher still
is fundamentally a good person he wants
to be good but they do kind of leave you
with a question that you know maybe he
will eventually cross the line at some
point
just like homelander eventually might
cross a line with
stormfront i'll talk about them in a
second too because that's part of a much
bigger storyline
but while they're busy breaking into the
compound and they find out about all
these superheroes they have a couple
really big comic book easter
eggs some of them more funny in a crazy
way than others
so they do love sausage from the comic
book he's russian just like he is in the
comic but it seems like the tv show
killed him off pretty quickly so i'm
guessing he's not going to be a huge
character in future episodes
you all know exactly what love sausage
is a reference to now if you didn't
before
i'll give you one guess as to what his
power was there's a couple more marvel
avengers and dc justice league
references with the powers in these
different cells there's one with super
strength there's one with
ant-man shrinking powers there's one who
spits acid
then the one that escapes at the end of
the episode after getting roasted by
stormfront
i believe cindy was her name she has
telekinesis and either super strength or
she just has really strong skin that the
bullets don't pierce
they also find out that lamplighter is
kind of like vaught's cleanup man now
that he's been kicked off the seven just
getting rid of all the evidence
so what happens here is as they test
these different patients when they're
done with them they just incinerate them
so i'm assuming that they have some
grand scheme to cover up their
identities so that nobody goes looking
for them
but number four obviously one of the
biggest parts of the episode lamplighter
explained so obviously you recognize him
he's a parody of green lantern in the
comics they also try to turn him into a
bit of a parody of the pyro character
which is more of an easter egg for his
x-men movie days and x-men the last
stand
i love that his lighter says titties on
it like they want you to think that he's
a terrible person
but most of what he tells you in the
episode makes you think that he's
actually kind of a good person
you get a pretty good sense for what
he's like in that moment when kimiko
winds up saving him from the acid
superhero who then winds up
accidentally burning his own face off
but the big deal with lamplighter is
that he used to be a member of the seven
they kicked him off
after the big incident with mallory's
children in order to prevent an
all-out war with the cia but the way
lamplighter explains it he didn't mean
to kill her children
she was the one that was supposed to be
in that bed so he feels really
remorseful about it and he's been
tearing himself up
ever since so frenchie's process of
working it out with lamplighter also
sort of helps his relationship with
kimiko
she's going to come around eventually
but obviously by the end of the episode
he sort of apologized to her
sorry you didn't need saving you didn't
ask to be saved
they've kind of been teasing a
relationship between the two of them
they might wind up paying that off by
the end of the season
you also learn a whole bunch more about
frenchie in these flashbacks with
lamplighter too
so it turns out one of the reasons why
he's been tormenting himself this whole
time
and why the group sort of torments him
is because they think that he let
lamplighter get away with it why didn't
you stop me then he reveals
that the reason why he didn't do that is
because he wasn't there when it actually
happened because he
left to go help his friends as messed up
as their backstory is there are a couple
funny moments too like when
mother's milk is talking about getting
engaged to his girlfriend in the
flashbacks then frenchie just demands to
throw him a bachelor party let me tell
you about the strippers that i'm gonna
bring to this crazy bachelor party
they also pull no punches when making
fun of a lot of the
pyro x-men characters when lamplighter
walks in they all just start breaking
into laughter openly just because he
looks so ridiculous
that's them just making fun of all those
classic x-men films especially x-men the
last stand
but then number three big starlight
finally kills someone in cold
blood so she just winds up getting that
random dude on the side of the road
pushing her in a darker and darker
direction making her feel
like she's more like butcher this is
also a bit of a comic book easter egg in
the comics
starlight does eventually wind up
joining the boys helping them out the
way she did in this episode
in just the same way that huey starts
out as this really pure
person at the beginning of the series
starlight started out as this really
religious person she seemed like such a
good girl
then through her actions and the actions
of the others around her
like the seven and the boys she becomes
darker and darker and darker and just
gets used to
all the things that they're doing the
same way that butcher has gotten so used
to being
so hardcore i do love the way that she
and butcher bond by the end of the
episode
standing over huey by making fun of him
like the little kid shampoo that he uses
and all the just weird things that he
does during the day
the number two big obviously the
mental patients on compound be all
escaping and just going crazy in the
hospital mother's milk gets himself a
taste of that old love sausage
which despite being super traumatized
based on all the flashbacks frenchie
still manages to make fun of later in
the episode
stormfront comes in kills pretty much
everyone thinks that she kills the cindy
character who then escapes at the end of
the episode will probably come back
around wanting some revenge against
stormfront
so there are a bunch of people that are
out for stormfront's blood now
including kimiko but the real number one
is obviously stormfront's true history
and her secret
grand plans that she reveals to
homelander so remember the theme that i
talked about in the episode
she and homeland are a little bit more
like a train in the deep than they are
like huey
in starlight she's part of a really
sinister
organization even though that
organization died off a long time ago
an evil organization with a grand plan
that's trying to rope in
new members so she tries to kind of
brainwash homelander into her cause
but she reveals that she was born in
1919 in berlin
you also notice that she dips into her
german accent too
she just learned over the years how to
hide that so she talks with an american
accent most of the time
but she is 101 years old in present day
she was the first person she says to
survive vaught's initial
compound v testing and became the first
real superhero
in germany during world war ii this is
them doing the actual stormfront comic
book plot with a couple minor changes
she says that she eventually got married
to vaught they had a child together and
that's the woman
in the picture with her that old woman
that people think is her grandmother no
this is my daughter she died a couple
years ago
but after world war ii when they came to
the u.s through operation paper clip
they hid her identity then many years
later rebranded her as the liberty
superhero
in the 60s and the 70s probably after
vaught had died of old age
she goes into full villain monologue
like true about her plan to
cleanse the world
quote unquote and dominate with an army
of supers created by vaught led by none
other than
homelander because he is their ultimate
achievement that they've been working
for the reason why they've been doing
all this testing
all these years and i think it's a bit
of a twist on a comic book easter egg
talking about volume 12 the bloody doors
off which the episode gets
its title from whether or not homelander
is really as terrible as people think
that he is
there's still two more episodes this
season i really want to see if
stormfront's going to survive to season
3 because there's still
so much comic book story they haven't
got to yet also really big news
yesterday they just announced that
they're doing a spin-off series for the
boys about their in-universe version of
what you would call the young avengers
pretty much so just imagine young
avengers teen titans references
on that series they didn't say win it
with premiere but i'm assuming 2022.
either way if you spotted any of the big
easter eggs or references in the episode
that i didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments
in my video for the boys season 2
episode 7 video we'll post next friday
they also just announced a suicide squad
tv show coming to hbo
in the next couple of years with john
cena's character from the new suicide
squad movie so i will do a teaser video
for that later today
everyone click here for that brand new
avengers one division trailer and click
here for the boys season 2
episode 5. Thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!